some of the bait some of the basics as
many of you know daughter is an obligate
parasite and it will wrap around its
host and it will actually make physical
attachments into the vascular system and
I'll show you some pictures of this what
makes daughter so successful as an
organism and so problematic as a pest is
the fact that it is a very prolific seed
producer and there are some notations
that one plant can produce more than
16,000 seeds which is just an incredible
amount of of seeds going into the seed
bank each year and once it becomes
established it has a tremendous growth
potential as a stem and has been
documented to grow about three inches in
a day also what makes it very
problematic in agricultural systems is
the fact that it has a very broad host
range it can attach to plan such as
tomatoes and carrots and trees and
grasses and many other many other plants
that are present within a production
system the seeds are incredibly
long-lived as you see there they can
actually survive going through an
animal's intestines and still come out
and be able to germinate one of the
biggest problems with cranberries is the
fact that the seeds are born in capsules
that can float and this is how they are
dispersed within the cranberry system is
during harvest the seeds are produced in
late august early September when we come
through and be harvest we knock all the
seed capsules off of the host and then
we can distribute them in our flood
water so the organism is very well set
up to take advantage of some of the
cultural practices that we use some
people might think that daughter does
not have any chlorophyll but actually
newly emerged seedlings may actually
contain a little bit of chlorophyll and
that does provide them with some energy
resources to get going prior to finding
a host and also what makes it tough is
that the detached
m's if you just go and pull stems off of
a host plant these stem can regenerate
and so this this also makes it very
difficult to manage I'd wanted to show
you some pictures of the historia which
is very characteristic of parasitic
plants and it is it is the way that
daughter gets into the host plant and
extracts the the carbohydrates and the
water from the xylem and the phloem and
this is what also makes it I'm so
successful so let's show a picture here
okay so if we look here let me get this
little arrow see if this works okay so
here we see a picture of the daughter
stem which is kind of like this
yellowish tissue right here here's the
plants epidermis kind of colored red and
here you can see how the historian is
actually penetrated through the
epidermis through the the secondary
xylem and is going right into the
vascular tissues so it actually has like
a penetration peg and here again is
another photo this is the daughter stem
that's going around the host plant right
here and here's about seven different
historia that are impregnating itself
into the host plant going right into the
vascular tissues so it just gives you an
idea of of how this plant operates and
what makes it so difficult to control
many of you familiar this is just a
bird's eye view of a pretty nice
infestation of daughter on a cranberry
field and up close this actual piece of
daughter pieces of daughter here have
been treated with Callista which is a
bleaching herbicide so that's why some
of these strands do look white here but
by and large you're going to have them
look as yellow or orange your strands
and here are the very small white
flowers that are very typical of
daughter as well so thinking about doing
some control of daughter and cram
what's interesting is that it really is
an excellent example of using integrated
management to control a particular pest
but the downside of that is it's that
because no one particular control method
works perfectly well so we must use many
different approaches to trying to
control daughter in any particular year
by and large the biggest thing is
prevention to keep it off your farm at
all costs initially that's the best
thing to do we'll talk more about each
of these options as we go through the
presentation but looking at
pre-emergence and post-emergence
herbicide use using short floods sanding
actually removing a daughter by hand and
using raking we did a survey a couple
years ago and pulled our growers just to
see what were some of their biggest
obstacles to control and this is you
know what they either listed as number
one is in the yellow bar or a number not
as number one and two together are in
the blue bars and you can see that the
small application window was what most
growers cited as their biggest obstacle
to control and that's we'll talk more
about that and that has a lot to do with
the biology of this particular parasite
certainly herbicide cost is a
consideration when to apply that kind of
fits in with a small application window
as well and what were some of the
practices that were used a couple years
ago we actually did have a section 18 to
be able to use curb which provided
excellent control for us we no longer
have that but Katherine was very popular
we still can use it and what's really
interesting is that hand pulling and
raking we're very commonly used where
you know among the top five for sure of
what growers would use to try to manage
past and as you'll see in the next slide
these were rated as being poor I mean
sixty-two percent of the growers rated
raking as being poor in hand pulling
being pork
role but still a lot of time and effort
is as being spent with these strategies
even though they don't provide the kind
of control that we'd like to see and
that just is a testament to how cable of
a weed pest daughter is so let's look at
some of the options that we have I kind
of put these in chronological order as
we go through the year so thinking about
sanding which typically tends to be a
winter spring practice that we do we did
a study several years ago about 10 years
ago now where we buried daughter seeds
under different depths of sand because
growers will typically put out about a
half an inch to an inch of sand and I
know these are in centimeters but that's
about a half an inch to an inch of sand
when they do this cultural practice and
we wanted to see what the impact would
be and we did the study twice and you
can see here that we need to get to
about an inch before we start seeing the
number of emerged seedlings going down
significantly we did see in the second
study there was a statistical difference
between zero and a half an inch but
again we saw a very nice reduction at an
inch of sand so that's primarily what
we've been recommending is if you want
to see any suppression of daughter
seedlings with sanding you need to go
with about an inch so the other key was
sanding is that there was some work that
was done by laura huntzberger as part of
her master's thesis looking at the
uniformity of sanding and it turns out
that our sin we put sand out on
cranberry bogs it does tend to be very
non-uniform so this could be the reason
that some growers even though they try
doing sanding for daughter control
doesn't always work because sometimes
you're not getting out the kind of depth
of sand that you would want and they
also made this note here of consider the
implications of sanding when you use ur
besides and that's primarily thinking
about count on that you don't want to
put Cassar on down first and then sand
on top of it because
you can definitely get some vine injury
when you do things like that so just to
keep those in mind and occasionally I
just wanted to note that in this
presentation if there are some
publications associated with the
recommendations I did note those in the
bottom of the slide so if you wanted to
go read the research articles you could
do that scouting is another process that
we do and this would normally happen
around late April early May for us in in
Massachusetts and we look for first
seedling emergence as a bio fix to help
us time some of our other application
and our other management methods such as
the application of herbicides or short
floods and i'll talk more about those we
look in warm spots or those harvest
areas on the side of the bog where you
pull your your fruit off that's a lot of
times where seed pods tend to be
deposited and you can have different
areas on the bog where you can try and
find these very small seedlings it is
quite challenging to look for these
seedlings and as you can see these
seedlings here that are pictured here
are probably about one to two days old
and they're very very small and just to
give you an idea of what you're trying
to find out on the bog here's a dime and
here are those small see links that I
just showed you and here is a seedling
that's probably about maybe three days
old or four days old so you really have
to pull apart the vines and really get
down on your hands and knees to try to
find these in the canopy and that's why
growers tend to go for these the bare
areas or the places where they pull off
their fruit as as more likely scouting
areas to find seedlings let's look at
some of the data that we've collected
over about the past 12 years looking at
the germination patterns of daughter and
this will tie into the whole scouting
and and how we try to figure out when to
apply our our management strategy of
either herbicides or floods or something
like that we started a study where we we
use simulated where we we build our own
little bogs and these five-gallon pails
and we
started one in 1997 and one in 1998
where we just dumped daughter seed into
these buckets and after that we added no
more and we just went every year and we
counted how many seedlings we got over
the entire season to try to see what the
germination patterns were so these
buckets are actually still out on the
bog and here we are in 2009 and they're
still having seedlings germinating which
gives you an idea of the longevity of
daughter seeds that are thrown out into
the farm what I want to show you here on
this particular graph so here's study
one which we started in 97 study 2 which
happened in 98 they were basically the
same except we had fewer seeds and study
two than we did in study 1 but basically
the pattern is what we really want to
look at here in the first year that we
put the seeds in we had the highest
germination rate and then after that
basically we had a bump here and study
one but basically the germination
declines over time okay and these
numbers here just represent this this
number here around a 5,000 for the mean
number of germination per container is
about eight percent of the total number
of seeds that we put in there so we put
a lot of seeds in the second study as I
mentioned we put much fewer seeds in but
we still got about the same number but
that's why you have a higher percentage
there but just just look at how you know
we have a very robust germination the
first year and then it declines over
time and so if we take if we try to
imagine this the germination pattern
that we've had over say a period of
eight years and that's what we have
represented over here with generation
one if you just imagine that being the
first seeds so like saying and 2009
seeds were produced and we think of
generation one as being the seeds that
are going to come out in 2010 these
would be the seeds in 2011-2012 and so
on
well we can see here is that in the
first year again we have a very robust
definitive peak of when seedlings
germinate and then it crashes back down
the other important thing to see on this
graph is the fact that here are all
these generations of seeds that have
been out on the bog and they're still
germinating at a low level but they're
also germinating later and later into
the year and so what I have here on the
axis is the Julian date which just made
it easier for us to try to work with the
year by year data but I've put in the
monthly approximations here so you can
see so here about is when late April is
which is when we are scouting for
daughter seedlings here is our peak
which occurs probably early May this
black line here shows when fifty percent
of the of the population is germinated
this little black line here shows when
ninety percent of the population has
germinated so we typically put on our
cast on applications here in mid-may so
you can see that we've missed the peak
and this Incarceron operates as a
pre-emergence and we have we're putting
on our herbicide applications too late
in this particular situation so that's
one problem which might explain why we
don't see the kind of response with
Cassar on that we would hope to see the
other take home with this graph is the
fact that we have all these seedlings
that are still germinating way out into
June and submit the middle of June that
can potentially be causing infestations
so I know I know that there's a lot of
information here and i'll be happy to
try to talk with people at a later date
with this but i just wanted to try to
get you i'm a perspective on why
daughter can be so problematic so the
the real things to consider here is that
the first germinating seedlings are
going to happen when you're going to be
scouting for these going to happen in
early April about fifty percent the
population is going to germinate in that
most
recently produced generation is going to
germinate by in early May ninety percent
is going to germinate by about the
middle of May and you have to consider
this viability issue the longevity of
daughter seeds is very key so by the
fact that we have a delayed first and
peak germination occurring over time
with these generations we end up having
this overlapping generation phenomenon
which prolongs the period of time that
seedlings are emerging and this is what
makes control so difficult so we can't
rely just on pre-emergence we must also
look at post-emergence another project
that we did was looking at flooding for
a non-chemical option again these
timings would be around the same as the
herbicide applications for Cass Iran and
again just to to show you what we did
here we did demonstration style bog by
bog comparisons so you know this is an
example of one of our sites where we
flooded one bog and did not flood the
other one and here's just the dike Road
in between so we had about seven
different paired sites and we flooded
this particular grouping here we flooded
them all for 36 hours in the middle of
May or so and we went out measured dry
stem weight and you can see where we
flooded and non flooded so here's the
flooded site we had significantly less
daughter biomass being produced in these
three different sites now our results
were not consistent because again here
we had three different sites noted by
their numbers 37 and to where we
actually ended up having more daughter
biomass in the flooded area then in the
non flooded area in two of the sites and
no difference in one of the sites now we
got to the point where we were wondering
if we would have had even greater
daughter in
flooded area if we hadn't flooded at all
because when we looked at the historical
infestation of the daughter we found
that this particular bog had a very very
high infestation so maybe we would have
produced 30 or 40 grams of stem s if we
hadn't flooded but we really couldn't
answer that question with this
particular study so the biggest take
home that happened with this is that the
growers actually really liked using this
particular flooding practice because
they felt that it really worked for them
so even though it didn't work so well or
consistently in our daughter in our
demonstration studies many growers have
embraced us and they've really felt that
it's helped to give them another option
we there's certainly more questions that
remain we've have followed the these
studies up with some incubator studies
we really couldn't show any difference
between flooding between 24 and 48 hours
but it does seem that the further you
get from first seedling emergence the
better control you get so if your first
sealing emerges in early April if you
tend to flood more like early May to the
middle of May you seem to get better
control but we still have a lot of work
to do here and and I'm just going to
move on just for time so Catherine use
is certainly a good pre-emergence
options that we have again timing is
very critical as I pointed out in the
with the whole pattern of germination
with daughter we typically use between
30 and 60 pounds per acre casts are on
volatilizes very quickly so it's very
important that you water it in
immediately and certainly one of the
concerns that we have is that the time
when we're applying caster on we're also
protecting for frost injury and if you
have to run your systems for you know
several nights of eight hours you're
likely to reduce the efficacy of casts
or on the control daughter you want to
watch in the spring if your temperatures
exceed 60 degrees because you're going
to lose herbicide to to the air 22 when
it volatilizes as I mentioned before
sanding after applying
cause injury and we typically see some
stress with Katherine and this exhibits
itself as cat as what we call yellow
vine syndrome we did a trial this year
where we looked at several varieties and
different timings to see if we could
actually go later in the year with a low
timing to try to go in early to mid June
to try to get some of those later
emerging populations and still get some
good control so we did four varieties
weekly applications and two different
rates so it turns out that there
definitely was a varietal response we
had the been leaders look particularly
sensitive with Stephens being the least
sensitive and there was also seemed to
be a weak response and notably right
here at week 4 which corresponds to
early June which would be about jewel
stage for most of those variety is when
we had the highest injury rating and
interestingly as we got later into June
till about the 15s or 20s of June we
started seeing lower injury which kind
of surprised us so this gives you an
idea this slide shows the Ben Lee or the
kind of injury that we saw this is
classic yellow vine syndrome kind of
getting this Christmas tree appearance
in the middle of the leaves and you can
see it right here this is very very
severe injury the house not so much so
thinking now going to post-emergence
options we did some additional work look
thinking about Callisto and we had
several different treatments that we did
multiple rates either before daughter
flowered applying once or doing two
applications making the first
application before flowering which is
what this is and then applying two to
three weeks later and then we also just
did a single application after flowering
and what we found pretty much is that
you know if you look at day 46 here this
is looking at the injury rating to
daughter so pretty much any of the
applications that we did before
flowering were much more injurious than
certainly the untreated and those that
we did after flowering so timing is
important when you're going after
daughter with Callisto we've actually
repeated this whole study this year but
we're still processing all the data we
also went through it looked at the
number of healthy seeds that we had and
and here again you can see we had over
200 healthy seeds produced with
untreated and this number went down
significantly with eight ounces and four
ounces two applications and one
application of eight ounces as well so
we're definitely having an impact on
daughter seed production so we were
really excited about the potential of
being able to use Callisto as a nice
post-emergence option but I'll certainly
feel a lot better about making that
recommendation once we get the second
year worth of data another option to go
post is using a manacle rake this was
some work again done by laura
huntzberger as part of her master's
thesis where she looked at multiple
farms so again here the strands were
broken but the historia were not removed
so there were some stem regeneration
concerns her data showed that removing
daughter once certainly reduced cover by
three-quarters by 74 75 percent there
was no additional benefit to raking more
than once and the yield loss that she
saw was mostly due to daughter but
certainly if you're out there doing some
very heavy raking you can just knock
fruit off and really negate any kind of
benefit that you might see otherwise
so I'm going to just click through these
data here just for the sake of time but
I've pretty much have captured it just
to go on and allow some time for
questions we did do two years of testing
in both Wisconsin and Massachusetts
looking at smoulder which was a
commercially available biocontrol prot
made from Alton area but unfortunately
it seemed to be very non effective we
tried it many different ways with many
different applications but we were just
not able to get this product to work in
the field and there is some other
products out there and they are
concentrated on Collett oricum and these
do look to be more promising and we hope
to be able to do some additional
research on those I do see that there
was a question on the timing of the
flooding I apologize that I didn't get
didn't see that earlier the fitting test
to be around the middle of May but we
still need to do more research on this
to find out when the best timing is so
again at this point I would look for
when the seedlings our first germinating
and then try to go about four weeks
after that a lot of times daughter
floods are coincide with when growers
want to flood for black-headed fireworm
so depending on their water resources
this may determine whether they could do
to short-term floods or if they just
combine them and try to get the best
that they can with it for the two
different pests I'm almost through so i
think i'm going to wait and just handle
the couple of questions at the end i
have a graduate student right now that's
looking at flame cultivation for
daughter control interestingly it seems
that wherever we use these flame
cultivators we seem to have our daughter
populations affected by colletotrichum
so we weren't able to really assess the
impact of flame cultivating on daughter
but we have certainly generated another
research question to see if the injury
caused by the the heat is making the
daughter
more susceptible to collet oricum
because we weren't even able and there
were like no seeds produced in these
plots that were treated but it wasn't
due to the flame cultivation was due to
the fungus coming in which was very
interesting so just as a take-home
checklist out of this at the end this
gives the whole host of things that we
can think of doing for daughter control
just to present it to you all on one
slide just for your information and as I
mentioned some of our future projects
you know we're going to try to continue
to look for other herb asides do more
work on short floods pursue this whole
call it a ChiCom issue and in
conjunction with flame cultivation and
see if these things work synergistically
we would really like to see if different
varieties are more or less susceptible
to daughter than others and we don't
really know and we've also initiated
some work looking at different plant
growth regulators to see if they could
help abort dadar seed production which
would go a long way to helping us manage
this pest so at that point that's all I
have I hope I didn't run too long and I
see that there's one question and I'd be
happy to entertain any other questions
if that's okay with you Laura
that's great Hillary thank you and I
love your final slide and my question
was just about not knowing a lot about
cranberry cult culture and production
I'm just wondering if there are other
weed problems oh there are absolutely
there's probably more than 80 different
weed species that have been identified
on cranberry bogs and we we tend to rank
them in for priority groupings based on
the ability to control them how quickly
they spread and how damaging they are to
yield and I would say our biggest ones
besides daughter are the dewberries the
rubus species poison ivy yellow
loosestrife and the saw briars which are
the smilax species those are probably
our biggies yep other okay thank you
does anybody else have it I realized
that that was a lot I act
no it was great and I actually have a
couple of poles that I apologize for not
posing to the group before your
presentation it might have helped you
know the layout of the entire group that
was listening and I'm going to introduce
those now before eric is speaking and so
it'll still give you folks a few more
minutes to ask Hillary some questions
and let me just get a little bit of
ideas about the makeup of the this group
so a few folks would just answer these
questions to the best of the ability you
can check more than one depending upon
what your role with very production is
and I was just going to mention too that
you had listed the UMass cranberry
station website as one of your resources
and the folks go to the homepage and
click on the webmaster and send
questions there those actually come
right to me so if people you know
afterwards want to try to follow up
that's one way you can get in contact
with me as well as my direct email okay
so I see Linda's asking if if daughters
native to Massachusetts or if it's
introduced I believe it's native to this
area it's it daughter is such a
ubiquitous plant that you can you can
find it in this in the swamplands
growing just about anywhere but as far
as it being native to cranberry bogs it
probably was brought in from the from
the wetlands and from some of the
uplands that surround the actual
production areas
i do want to mention to it looks like in
my poll i made an error on the very
final choice it says blueberry industry
support i really should just say very
industry support meaning if you're a
nurseryman or a salesperson we'd love to
find out that too and it does look like
we had about 21 people that have given
us some feedback please don't be shy i
would love to hear from you i also want
to say one quick thing that for those of
you there's a couple of names that I
don't recognize on the attendee list
which means that perhaps you were
forwarded the connection information
which is not a problem except that we
really need to keep track of who is
attending and because we are going to be
sending some evaluations out to you
folks this is a fairly new a delivery
system for information and we are going
to be really trying to evaluate the
effectiveness of it get your responses
so some surveys will be coming your way
I want I really request that you're
going to be
patient with them and try to answer them
to the best of your ability because that
information would be very very important
to us as we use this webinar type format
in the future
okay we've got somebody that's
let me to see if I can make that pull a
little bit larger so that the Geneva
site can see yep and okay as far as the
other weeds we're actually still finding
out what Callisto does control but it
seems to do an excellent job on nutsedge
which is a Cypress species it seems to
do a pretty good job on clover narrow
leaf goldenrod growers have reported
that it actually does we can poison ivy
we've seen it impact are the saw briars
and the Dewberry so I don't know whether
I would say that it actually controls
them but it certainly bleaches them out
and and stunts their growth so there's
there's many grasses that it controls as
well but certainly nuts edges is a good
one that it does a great job on so it
looks like I've kind of lost my question
ability to see but that's okay no no
that's okay not a problem how I I'll be
staying on for the I know tool for erics
talk as well so if if there's other
questions but thank you all for for
listening i see that there's a lot of
blueberry growers and i'm sorry that i
didn't attend to more blueberry issues
well we had hoped actually I thought
that there were going to be some
cranberry people on because we did have
some folks register and I'm not totally
sure what happened there but fortunately
this will be archived so that cranberry
growers can no problem my pleasure
mation Hillary and I really appreciate
it it was fascinating and now we're
going to great we're going to close this
and we'll get Eric Hanson introduced
here I also want to let folks know that
you do have the ability if you'd like to
have the presentation pod and large to
fill your whole screen you can do that
let me get there we go there's Eric's
picture and I'm going to actually
introduce our next speaker is dr. Eric
Hansen he is a professor and extension
extension specialist at Michigan State
University he focuses on applied
questions relating to fruit production
with an emphasis on berries and along
with season extension
and some fertility work he also does
weed control and cover cropping work so
it's wonderful to have you dr. Hansen
and yeah thank you I'm real happy to be
participating in this and thanks so much
for organizing it Laura I was asked to
cover blueberry weed management so I'll
cover some of the basics and was also
asked to talk about some things that
might be a little bit newer and I'll try
to try to do that as well so the
chemical tools will go through
pre-emergent and post emergent
herbicides that are commonly used in
blueberries what they do how to choose
them and then some chemical cultural
approaches as well including mulch use
cultivation and and some other other
things as you probably know if you grow
blueberries they don't compete well with
weeds there there is low-growing plant
and they're overrun with weeds very
quickly they don't fill their space and
if you don't control the weeds when the
bushes are small they may never fill
their space and there are a number of
reasons for this first they compete with
the plants for water nutrients and light
sometimes we don't think about the
shading that weeds tall weeds and cause
they also disrupt sprays and can promote
some diseases and insect pests for
example sass Sassafrass weeds and a
blueberry patch or a great magnet for
japanese beetle so if you have sassafras
or grape vines in your blueberry patch
those will tend to attract Japanese
beetle into the patch as well and then
some weeds produce fruit which
and actually get to enter mixed with the
harvested blueberries and adulterate the
product which can be particularly
concerning if it's a poisonous fruit so
a lot of reasons for controlling weeds
I'd like to make the point though that
you like any good thing you can overdo
it so here is a what I consider a
perfectly managed blueberry patch so
this this area here has no weeds this is
late in the summer it suggests to me
that this grower might have applied too
much herbicide I'd like to see some
manual weeds breaking through and
covering the ground late in the season
late in the season blueberry bushes will
tolerate some competition from weeds
it's not that concerning and this grower
has also cultivated and you're probably
aware that repeated cultivation
diminishes the quality of of soils so if
he's doing this without adding any
organic matter eventually that will
reduce the quality of the soil in that
patch so the point is I guess is that
you can overdo it by the end of the
season you would like to see some low
growing weeds establishing in your
blueberry field so our blueberry weed
control recommendations are all outlined
each year on this in this publication so
it's updated each year and you can order
that publication from this this website
and a lot of the information i'll talk
about today is in that publication and i
think it's a real valuable publication
for for any commercial grower
so we should talk about pre-emergent
herbicides which are applied generally
before weeds emerge they act through the
soil to control germinating seedlings
and some established weeds and then post
emergent nur besides are applied
directly to weeds that are already
present there is an overlap of some of
these so I did Callisto for example
which Hillary talked about as a
pre-emergent herbicide but it's also
applied post emergent to control weeds
that are already up and growing so types
of weeds number of different annual
weeds these are some of the common
annual weeds and Michigan blueberries
and I'm sure you're familiar with these
if you grow blueberries and you can
probably add to add to this list so
those are the broadleaf some broad leaf
weeds the pre-emergent herbicides we try
to give in IE 15 for publication a
indication of the relative suitability
of different or besides against
different weeds so here we're looking at
some of the broadleaf annual weeds and
the effectiveness of different
pre-emergent herbicides and you can see
that they vary substantially depending
on the on the weed and the the material
so for the broadleaf annual weeds Cassar
on for example is pretty strong across
the board and and we in Michigan
generally think of carmex and and
prinsep as being strong annual broadleaf
weed control materials
now here are some ratings of the same
herbicides for control of annual grasses
and and things change somewhat here so
Katherine is not so strong what seems to
be rated most consistently good against
annual gases is Devon all oh we think a
sim bar Sola cabin and cerflan is all
being good annual grass materials
perennials blue blazer perennial plant
and as a result a lot of the most
difficult weeds to control tend to also
be perennial species these are some that
we think of as being a CodeRed type of
weeds and Michigan blueberries in that
they're noxious enough and invasive
enough to where you really should make a
concerted effort to try to eliminate
these when you first see them so that
they don't become established in your in
your blueberry patch and these are
common ones in Michigan and I'm sure you
can add more to this list so let's look
at those same yer besides for their
relative effectiveness against these
selected perennial weeds well callisto
not particularly a good Katherine
provides some level of control of some
of these sin bar provides some level of
control of some of these but you'll
notice that none are rated with four
stars for excellent control so the point
is that these pre-emergent materials
provide some control of perennial weeds
but not very good control so my point is
that you should think about your
pre-emergent program in the spring as a
way of controlling the annual weeds that
are present
and think about other ways of
controlling some of these hard to
control perennial weeds so let's talk
about annuals in Michigan we can usually
provide summer long control of most
annuals by using the appropriate
herbicide at the appropriate rate and at
the appropriate time now in order to do
that you need to know first the weeds
that are present and I made a note of
what I think is the best weed ID book
available is the weeds of a northeast at
a Cornell University Press it's a
wonderful publication if you want to
identify weeds in your blueberry patch
we also have quite a few of more
troublesome weeds listed on our webpage
at MSU ww berries msu edu so you might
want to take a look at that that site as
well so for annual weed control then
generally this requires a application of
a pre-emergent herbicide about the time
that the weeds begin to emerge in the
spring so April or May depending on your
location in Michigan we normally ban
this and about a five foot wide strip
beneath the bushes and then we try to
maintain some kind of a annual crop such
as annual rye or perennial side between
the rows I wanted to make the point that
these label rates of herbicides or four
acre a per acre of treated surface area
so if we're only treating half of this
acre our actual amount
verb aside we're using will be half of
the labeled rate so let's look a little
more specifically at some herbicide
programs first considering young plants
so these would be one in two year old
plants sometimes I think also you should
consider small plants or weak plants
that haven't been getting enough water
haven't been taken care of properly so
they might be older than two years but
two years in in size so here these
plants are less tolerant of some of the
pre-emergent herbicide so we normally
think about the the safer herbicide
products and those might be Devon all in
gallery and cerflan so those could be
applied in the spring they're not as
effective or long-lasting as some of the
more effective materials but they're
safer on these young plants that have
less tolerance to herbicide you can also
spot treat blueberries with post
emergent materials keep in mind that
these post emergent materials listed
here are non selective so they will kill
blueberries as easily as they'll kill
weeds so take care and using those
during in these young plantings you can
also use post and fusillade can to
control grasses and of course
cultivation is a pretty important tool
for young plantings
so moving to establish blueberries the
workhorse pre-emergent herbicides in
Michigan for quite a few years have been
carmax and prinsep sandbar and silicon
there are other materials uses used and
a few new materials that have recently
been labeled but these are the materials
that are used for the most part we think
of carmex and princep as being strongest
on broadleaf weeds and sim bar and Sola
camp being best on grasses so growers
normally are thinking about using these
in combination so it might be carmax
with sim bar or carmax with Sola camp so
that growers can achieve good control of
broadleaf and grass grass weeds
I wanted to talk a little bit about
herbicide resistance not that it's as
big a problem and blueberries as it is
and agronomic crops but it certainly can
and does occur so in avoiding resistance
to herbicide the key is to alternate or
rotate between herbicide zeeeee with a
different mode of action and the the
important thing to understand with
blueberry or besides is that there are
four of the common herbicides carmax
princep sin bar and Val par that all
share the same mode of action so if you
develop a population of weeds with
resistance to prinsep for example that
population will also be resistant to
carmax as well as sim bar so it does you
no good to rotate between prinsep and
carmax in alternate years because you're
using chemicals with the same mode of
action fortunately we have a number of
different herbicide now with entirely
different modes of action so you can
choose herbicide sand and i color-coded
them here with a wide range of different
modes of action
we did a little bit of work surveying
the blueberry industry in Michigan a
number of years ago for resistance to
the triazine herbicide so that includes
simazine and turbo and Val par for
example but it also includes the other
photosynthetic inhibitors carmax and sim
bar and what we found was that there
were smart we'd what populations that
were resistant in Michigan blueberries
and very wide widely scattered
populations of mares tail that were
resistant to these triazine herbicides
and I would suspect their there are more
we have common complaints by growers
about lack of control of a number of the
pig weeds for example but it's something
to keep in mind that over time you don't
want to stick specifically and only with
those photosynthetically photosynthetic
and hit up inhibitor type of herbicides
and then post emergent or besides these
are several that are labeled for use in
blueberries and the key differences here
that I think you should be aware of our
weather there nonselective or selective
and whether they're trans located within
the plant so roundup and touchdown for
example or non selective it means they
kill all all things green it they're
trans located within the plant which
means that they're very effective weed
killers for a number of different crops
because the herbicide is moved down into
the roots of the plant depending on when
it's applied and can control even
perennial weeds as well as other
perennial plants such as blueberries
a selective type of post emergent
herbicide would be that the post
emergent grass killer is post and
fusillade so those have no effect on
broadleaf weeds but they control grasses
and they are also translocated and then
there are another couple of materials
gurram acts own and rely which are non
selective but generally not translocated
in plants so that means that they kill
the tissues that they contact but they
aren't transportation into other parts
of the plant and they aren't
particularly effective in controlling
perennial weeds as a result so all of
those with the exception of the grass
killers can potentially damage
blueberries which leads to the question
of how you apply those without injuring
your blueberries at the same time and
there are a number of approaches here
there's some shielded hoods such as this
product by enviro missed this is on a
swivel swivel arm so it the hood can
move in and out between the blueberry
bushes it's a relatively slow covering
acreage but for smaller plant things I
think it does a good job of keeping the
herbicide off of the base of the plants
for these pre-emergent or these
perennial weeds that are difficult
control I think a key time is post
harvest so after harvest of weed these
perennial weeds that are treated with
glyphosate can easily be killed the
material moves down into the roots this
is when you can get a complete kill of
perennial weeds whereas if you treated
those weeds in the May or June as
they're just growing you may damage the
top of the plant but not kill the entire
plant so this is what I think should be
a a common annual practice once you get
done with harvest is to spot treat of
perennial weeds that you see in your
planting if you don't do this on a
regular basis so those perennials don't
disappear they'll continue to grow and
spread throughout the planting there are
a number of different keys to this first
apply late in the season ammonium
sulfate can be added to increase the
penetration of the herbicide but I
wanted to again make the point that if
you wanted to kill blueberries with
glyphosate this would be the great time
to do it so make sure that you avoid
contact with all green blueberry tissues
that means the leaves as well as the
bark on those one-year-old shoots that
grew the previous year so round up will
be absorbed by this tissue the next
summer you'll see the distorted leaves
if those shoots leaf out at all of many
cases it will they'll be dead in the in
the spring so however whichever way you
choose to use roundup in the fall of the
year make sure you're avoiding contact
with any green blueberry tissue in some
cases here here are a couple of pictures
of grapevine and then while blackberry
and blueberries it this may require
pulling those weeds down out of the bush
so that you can safely treat them with
Roundup while keeping it off of the
blueberry bush mulching I wanted to
mention a few things about about
mulching as a weak control practice it's
not not wonderful Organic mulches are
costly to purchase and costly to apply
and they have other disadvantages in
that bark and wood chips or a great
great site for various rodents these
generally do not prefer to chew on
blueberry roots but they certainly do
and to some extent the other aspect of
these organic mulches is that they don't
control all perennial weeds so
eventually you'll have perennials coming
up through that mulch
we did a little bit of work starting a
couple years ago with different mulch
types in an organic blueberry project
and these are the treatments so some
synthetic materials as well as burlap
hay and straw and wood chips and bark
nuggets and and chipped chipped would we
have for two years taken a tally of the
time required to weed these plots and
then extrapolated the numbers we got to
a per acre basis and if you do that what
we found was that with no mulch to keep
those plots completely controlled of
weeds this would cost about fifteen
hundred dollars per acre per year
assuming that your leaders are paid ten
dollars an hour and you can see as you
go down down the list of what the annual
weeding labor costs would be for you
another approach to weed management that
some growers use is cultivation so of
course the big question with cultivating
between established perennial plants is
how do you disturb the soil without
destroying the plants and there's at
least one manufacturer rotary hose
that's available right now there was
what grower a number of years ago in
Michigan that managed all weeds with
these rotary hose on a 60-acre blueberry
farm and he would go over his acreage
two to three times during the season
and he essentially had high school kids
running tractors all the time so the
rate typically is about a half an acre
per hour so it does take quite a bit of
time but if it's a smaller farm smaller
acreage perhaps this is an approach this
is not a entirely safe approach and that
you certainly catch blueberries
occasionally
and then lastly I wanted to mention
something that doesn't really relate to
in role weed control but impressed me
quite a bit it does relate to vegetation
management in the role metals so in
Michigan it's common for blueberry
growers to seed annual rye between the
row metals in September and then they
may cultivate that or mow it or let it
see doubt the following year we were
working in a organic blueberry planting
on campus and cover crop specialists
brought this crimper in to run down the
rows of rise so you can see this was
heading out this crimper would move down
knock the ride down and then it would
crimp the stems of the rise so it
wouldn't stand back up so it's a little
bit different than just rolling it down
but the the neat thing about that was
that we crimped a stand awry in early
June and then this picture was taken of
the row middle in the middle of August
so over two months later we're starting
to get some of those annual weeds
breaking through the mat of crimped rye
but I thought it was a neat system and
could work in an organic setting but
particularly for establishing new
plantings I think this I was pretty
impressed with the amount of suppression
of weed growth that that Madame Raya
provided so that's a about all I wanted
to cover Laura I talked a little bit
about the
weed management systems and in a couple
of couple of newer things I hope I
generated maybe some questions or or
some comments all right thank you very
much Eric and we do have some questions
Molly Shaw asked for growers from mulch
heavily with woodchips greater than 8
inches which soil texture class would
they use for herbicide rates and that is
a good question because that's something
the kind of struggle with was trying to
figure out with a high organic matter
yeah that's a wonderful common question
and I really can't answer a very well
there's relatively little mulching in
Michigan blueberries and I haven't done
any herbicide trialing and mulched
settings so I I would suggest that you
start with a low end and do some
experimenting with your soil type and
your mulch type and mulch amounts to see
what levels you need for confer control
okay Gary Phelps is wondering what rate
do you need for Chateau on high mulched
ground in blueberries that may also be a
challenge
yeah I again with chateaux if you were
mulching you would probably need a
higher higher rate than then if you were
not mulching but I really can't tell you
what control you'd expect from that we
haven't worked with it here um we also
have a question from larry flakis he's
wondering what the best control is for
bindweed well yeah the two of we have
hedge bindweed and the common bindweed
and Michigan blueberries and the control
the only reasonable control of it that
I've gotten is with round up at the
recommended rates and recommended time
so when when the vines are flowering
they're generally susceptible to round
up and that's the only only solution I
can offer right now
okay we have a couple of other questions
about specific read problems alan baker
is wondering what the control options
for Bishop weed or doubt we'd are um and
I'm sorry I I don't have any experience
with gout weed
um Gary Phelps is wondering about ground
straw and a control of ground strong I'm
I am not familiar with this particular
weed so maybe there's another name for
it we fed reasonable control with sin
bar on ground straw it's one of those
low growing weeds where I question
whether you need to control it entirely
if it's not up into the bushes perhaps
it's something that you can tolerate and
then there's another question from Jeff
Miller about what are the manufacturers
that are producing the wipers
do you happen to know and maybe somebody
else in the attendees some of the
manufacturers of herbicide wipers yeah I
haven't looked into wipers for for quite
some time I think I'd get on the web
there are a number of different types we
had done some work years and years ago
with a hockey stick stick type wiper
they they do a good job with Roundup but
it's just so slow it's it's hard to
cover much acreage with them does
anybody else have any questions that
they would like to pose for either
Hillary or Eric and Hillary says we use
voice is quite extensively and
cranberries so that would be great maybe
Jeff and Hillary can talk about that if
anybody has any other questions will
move into the final phase
actually there is one more question from
Aaron coats about controlling red duck
and
perhaps Eric you have a suggestion for
that red doc I'm thinking might be red
soil if that's a case Katherine provides
a reasonable control of that and then
there's a comment by Marvin Prince about
why don't more people use wheat straw as
a mulch since it's easy to acquire maybe
there's some feeling about that I always
thought that straw would draw some bowl
and mold problems and that that was a
reason to discourage its use but it
looked really like it might do an
effective job as a as a mulch there so
that was interesting
yeah our experience with it it smothered
weeds wonderfully it requires higher
nitrogen rates if you're using that but
I i agree i think it probably has
utility it doesn't have the longevity
perhaps of some of the wood materials
but like you say it's cheap and
available right
um I do want to draw everyone's
attention before they start logging off
we don't have any other poll questions
but I want to make sure that you see
these file shares here for folks to a
download to get more information i also
want to one of the attendees drew to my
attention that i did not introduce dr.
Hillary Sandler and I apologize for that
that is my mistake but I really
appreciate her patience with me and
forth i'm glad we got her connecting so
i was a great presentation and dr. Eric
Hanson I really appreciate your
presentation and I do want to remind
those of you who did not descend me
registration information but got the
logon connection information from
someone else please email me I'm just
going to type my email address into the
chat box here and just send me your
postal address your email address and
your phone number so that we have that
on record and at this point unless
scoops there's one more question why
establish an annual cover crop between
rows and I think that must be for you
Eric
yeah well the there a couple of
approaches here there there were a
number of growers in the state that used
perennial sides and blueberries and over
the last several years they've gotten
away from those because they tend to
attract Japanese beetle so Japanese
beetle females lay eggs inside and so
that increases that that problem growers
also like bare soil in cold areas
because it tends to be a little bit
warmer on those frosty spring night so I
think in in Michigan where it's a frost
prone area bare soil in the spring is
appealing
all right great Thank You speakers dr.
Sandler and dr. Hanson again I do want
to remind folks that you know that
you're all registered you will be
receiving connection information for all
of the future very webinars the next
webinar on our docket is on Wednesday
November 18 it's actually a very
important topic we're going to be
talking about cranberry and blueberry
disease management dr. Frank caruso from
the cranberry station at University of
Massachusetts will be talking about
cranberry viruses and dr. Anna Meeks
shoulder will be talking about blueberry
viruses and for both cranberry and
blueberry growers these are very very
serious and important disease problems
and I encourage you to attend and tell
other growers the same about the
this program all right that's it and
thanks again ok thank you and we'll see
you in a couple of weeks
oh yeah
you
you
I don't know if I'm still here or not hi
Hillary oh ok so yeah so I saw the Jeff
still had a question I don't know if
he's still on and he might be and I was
just trying to type my answer but maybe
we can both chime in it did it does seem
to me that most of the Michigan and
that's what I would think go that yeah I
think I think Maine is primarily the
only place it's still in low bush
but Eric Eric chopped off already so he
probably would have been the best yeah I
think I think main as from my work
trying to get some statistics for the
very proud pretty much the highbush
blueberry was New Jersey in Michigan and
then
main was although bush yeah well thank
you it was really it was a great
experience and now I'll remember next
time select microphone and and you said
that these will be archived someplace
and you'll let us know they will yes
i'll send you the link it's on the
Cornell Barry website and we have three
of the four strawberry lumps up now and
I'll try to send this out as soon as
possible so that it will be and then you
could just put that link right into some
of your cranberries great nation and so
that they could also eat to it and yeah
and the nice thing especially about
yours is they don't they can go and
listen to your presentation and if they
don't grow blueberries they don't right
listen right now I'm not so sure yeah
the blueberry growers I think you kind
of have to listen through the whole
thing in order to get to it I'm not
positive that they can kind of fast
forward
okay I guess we'll find that okay that's
okay i think it looks oh so it'll
actually be so today's webinar so mine
is linked to eric's so they would have
to listen through mine to get to his or
wit okay yes we okay yeah which i think
it will be good it'll be okay I think
people will actually be really
interested in hearing about cranberries
you know most of the shorter throughout
it but I was a great pre no problem well
I think this has been a great you know
I'm glad the Northeast I p.m. is
supporting something like this I think
this is a great thing and them I'm going
to try to chime in on or listen to the
disease one on the 18th that sounds
great so i will i will register okay
okay okay all right you take care I can
register all righty bye-bye okay take
care bye bye
you